[Music]
you heard this like soft quitting
something about there's like some term
on tick tock that has like three million
videos now or something like that a
quiet quitting it's like when you quit
your job but you just like you don't
actually quit you just do as little as
possible oh yeah it's a big trend now
gen z is ditching hustle culture i mean
i get it half of jobs are just [ __ ]
yeah i mean if you work for like a fang
company you definitely can do this
easily i've known like five people fang
company like facebook apple amazon
netflix google got it this guy quite
quitting right here let's see what's
good yeah what does this mean let's see
[Music]
bro
[Music]
dog quiet quitting everyone in a retail
job is doing that
tech dudes just discovered what everyone
at a hourly wage job does yeah that was
my favorite [ __ ] at best buy just trying
to do as little as possible and just
hiding places manager coming around the
corner he's like man the [ __ ] are you
doing in home phones oh no i was talking
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] you weren't no one buys [ __ ]
from this aisle what home phone home
phones bro
home phones the displays for those shits
were it was just like it was just like
phone bases with missing phones
and then grandma's coming in saying like
does this one that do flash what are you
doing at home phones selling them yeah i
had i already had like five customers
yeah i'm really really they bought a
home phone yep now shit's going crazy
yeah landlines are like they're picking
back up
literally yeah yeah
that's all it was always be like some
geriatric person who's like i need to be
able to do three-way and speaker
and will this work with my hearing aids
i don't know man
you just have to cop it and find out
yeah or or you're trying to waste time
with them yeah keep them on the hook on
the horn you just like um i don't know
what is your what is your hearing
condition exactly well uh you would do
that bro but then it would then it would
turn a corner where you're like okay
now you're just here to talk oh yeah and
it's time to go yeah you know god bless
old people they're lonely but you know
for like whatever [ __ ] 9 15 hour i
was making wasn't enough for me to have
a conversation the best was when you get
a dude like a dad with a big family and
you come in and say i need i need a
system that has nine phones
[ __ ]
this one
it only does only has three which one of
these has nine i don't [ __ ] know dude
yeah yeah literally just because i have
a blue polo on you think i know which
phone has nine
i don't that actually i [ __ ] stand by
that because the crazy entitlement
people would have they just
that k that karen [ __ ] rings a different
bell for me because those people would
come into best buy and you you might be
like walking in from your lunch you
clearly have a hoodie on they just see
your khakis and they're like hey hey
which printer yeah no no it'd be like
why don't you have any cd portable cd
players and i need one with the
anti-skid i don't i don't know i don't
work in this department you don't know
you don't know
you people you don't know anything in
this store excuse me can you help me in
home phones yeah yeah now the best would
be when someone would come in and they
come in with their [ __ ] printer ink
from a printer that was from like three
years ago they're like i'm looking for
this
your guess is as good as mine buddy have
at it nobody knows how these [ __ ]
things work no because all the printer
ring too it was stolen oh nice
you'd see people they're like oh i need
um an hp 96 black uh okay yeah and then
you see the package you're like oh for
sure and they'd be like yes and you grab
it and it would squeeze and you're like
oh someone stole it
why did people steal printer ink because
it was just it was easy to style
so easy okay i get it like even if i was
a working person i saw like 72 dollars
for black ink
so there we go we found another another
small heist there we go yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah printer ink was yeah by the
way a lot of people said yes that they
do like they walk into chipotle and grab
other people's meals and stuff like that
i only read a couple of the comments but
some of them were like yeah my boyfriend
does that [ __ ] the system yeah
it's just nice to know that other people
have thought of that yeah damn now i'm
going through the other rackets that
best buy the people would do oh you know
there's another funny section home like
there was a year where they were still
selling boom boxes nice but like the
four speaker system versions there was a
whole aisle for those [ __ ] yeah and
people would be asking questions like
hey does this like
have something like
[Laughter]
find out yes
just yes it does oh great so i can
connect yep
yeah
yeah for sure yeah i can hook up my xbox
controller to this yeah you could try
[Laughter]
man i'm getting flashbacks we used to
sell [ __ ] we used to sell antivirus
in the box oh yeah that's a real good
racket right there yeah put this malware
on your computer
no no it finds malware just any software
you have to install via cd yeah that's
so funny yeah i think they still sell
this [ __ ] they don't know
i think they sell them on like little
cards and they have like uh keys on them
oh yeah just go to a link and so it's
not a cd anymore nah but best buy
computers were the worst because they
pre-load them with so much [ __ ] it'd be
hilarious when someone would drop
literally two grand on some super fast
laptop and they'd bring it back in two
days and go it's so [ __ ] slow
all these games and like
[ __ ] language learning apps and
just like dumb ass [ __ ] came with mario
type or pre-installed
you the most ear piercing sound in a
retail job
right here excuse me
[Laughter]
people yell it like that if anyone
that's worked in a big box retail store
they know that voice excuse me
it's gender fluid you have no clue who
is on the other side of that voice could
be a 42 year old man it could be a 30
year old woman could be a like a
[ __ ] 19 year old teenager just
someone whenever we did inventory like
we had to restock the store i would just
scream that [ __ ] from across the
we had this one manager who'd be like
noel stop
everyone would think there was someone
still in the store
that's really good excuse me
someone help me with the phones
i'm just recalling how i brought up how
we uh people used to [ __ ] do the
peyton manning with hard drives
oh yeah
it is so bad dude was it were they like
hard drives with [ __ ] on them bro they
were brand new hard drives that people
could buy to like put into their
computers so if you drop one it's like
broken it's like it's like the disc so
somebody would buy it and then it
wouldn't work bro
i would be so annoyed because these
inventory dudes gave no [ __ ] and they'd
be like oh hey there's a there's a hard
drive down over here
they'd be like oh is it yo send it to me
i'm i'll stalk it right now
they would always go like
like [ __ ] throw their hands up and
then pull them away and you see that
just [ __ ]
[Laughter]
damn dude that's [ __ ] up so [ __ ] and
printers only two printers they used to
like look like stuff on forklifts
dude it'd be like a stack of five and
they just like kick them so they just
like fall onto the top with like some
dead stock area or like when they stalk
them you hear them like slam them down
and some some supervisor might be like
yo chill like be nice with that they'd
be like oh for sure
we have so many people come back like i
just bought these printers in three
pieces yeah it's a three-piece printer
yeah
[ __ ] you know man that was quiet
quitting dude
that was that's not it's not that quiet
it really isn't it's not that quiet yeah